Hey everybody.
My name is Gabriel Dylan. It's a pleasure
to be here and to be able to speak with you guys
today about personalization, about
content, about artificial intelligence.
Um, I represent Contentful, which is
a digital experience platform,
uh, for building all sorts of different
kinds of experiences across many different kinds
of channels.
I'm very, very honored to speak to
you today, and I wanna thank AWS
for their amazing partnership. I'll
talk about this later on,
but Contentful is native
to AWS and the trust and
scalability that we provide to our clients
is in large part due to the trust
and scalability that AWS provides
to us.
So, thank you, AWS.
for the opportunity and for you guys for
coming and speaking to me today.
We're going to talk about supercharging personalized
experiences
with contentful
NAWS, in particular, Amazon Bedrock.
OK, so, one would think
that with the ability to generate an infinite
amount of content that marketers would be
super happy, right?
Because now suddenly they don't have to do their job
anymore. I would be pretty happy too.
But there's actually a huge problem
with being able to deliver
high-quality experiences today in the age
of artificial intelligence and the ability
to Generate content with the click
of a button.
Specifically, it's that so much
of that generated content
is
generic.
It's dumb, it's generic,
it's boring, it's, it's just not
interesting enough to be able to drive the kinds
of behaviors that we as
brands, as organizations want
our clients and customers to do.
And customers know it, when they receive
those types of messages from your website or your
app, they get bored.
We call this the great content collapse.
The analogy that I wanna sort of offer
for you is if you remember like way back
in like 2011, there was a
UI library that was released called
Bootstrap.
Does anybody remember Bootstrap?
Yeah.
And then all of a sudden, all the websites
looked exactly the same.
Now we're doing the same thing with the
copy, we're doing the same thing with the images.
We sound boring
to our clients.
And
it's happening at the beginning of the funnel, the middle of the funnel,
and the end of the funnel. By the way, if it's not
clear, this is a marketing talk. It's
not an infrastructure talk, but I'll cover
some infrastructure topics as well.
So
this is breaking our marketers. This
content collapse is breaking our marketers
across the board.
They're asked to create more with
fewer resources and supposedly
artificial intelligence is supposed to
solve the problems that they encounter
along the way.
Down at the bottom of our funnel,
we're supposed to have
really loyal.
Customers who experience
Being spoken to as individuals,
but they're just still served the same generic
content that they received when they were at the top
of the funnel.
The paradox that we talk about here
is that we have a whole bunch of speed,
but we've lost relevance, we've lost
the ability
to address our users as humans.
In fact,
what's happened is that artificial intelligence
has offered this new skill
set that is separate from the
content layer that we use to be able to
govern workflows, to be able to
publish content, and distribute really
great stories to our users.
My CMO Elizabeth Maxson
recently collaborated with The Atlantic
on a big think piece. There'll be a webinar
in a week or so,
uh, and what we're calling it is this
big sort of, uh, misunderstanding
about what artificial intelligence is. Doing
to marketers,
it should really be making marketers more
human. It should be freeing them up
to
be more creative, to be able to
think more about their users, and to be able
to publish
content that speaks to individuals based off of what
they need.
And instead what we're getting is something
much worse.
It's because the artificial intelligence
is at the wrong part of the marketing stack.
It's in this sidebar. You guys have seen
the AI sidebar,
but why isn't it actually part of the content layer
itself? So,
as I mentioned, my name is Gabriel Dylan. I'm
the practice uh lead for our
personalization product. So we're gonna talk
quite a lot about personalization and how it solves
some of the problems associated with
generic content.
But first, let's take a moment and
talk about personalization in a more general
sense,
because quite frankly, personalization is not new,
it's not an artifact of artificial
intelligence. We've been trying to create
custom curated, tailored
journeys that are highly relevant for a very
long time,
but it often fails.
It often fails, not because the
technology is bad, it is actually getting much
better these days, but because of the people
and the processes that are used
to be able to create the experiences
that are supposed to be personalized.
And there's a bunch of different ways in
which those sorts of processes fail.
There's siloed content,
which is caused by bas,
it causes bad cross-channel experiences,
you know, you get a really great email and then you land
on the website and it's
completely different.
There's super
superficial personalization, that's often
what gives people the ick factor when you suddenly
start using
their name and they're like, you don't know me
website, like I'm, I'm just doing my thing and
why are you talking to me like we're friends?
There's inaccurate personalization where you actually
try to leverage some customer data, but
it's out of date or
it's not really integrated well.
There's redundant experiences
when
maybe a marketer got really clever and created
an aspect that was very powerful,
but it's only in one little piece of the
experience, and then they come to another spot and
there's some discordant dissonance.
There's also poorly measured experiences
where
There's no feedback loop,
so the marketing organization that's trying to create
these experiences doesn't know if
it's actually working, if it's actually moving
the needle and driving behaviors the
way that they would want.
And then lastly, there's the dependence on
developers.
To be able to be
fast,
to be able to create content that
captures a moment in time,
we need our marketers to be freed
from the ticket queue and
the requirements of the front end.
In the report in The Atlantic, we talk about
like this optimism optimism
versus expectation gap.
Like everybody knows that personalization
is the answer. It should make my
job really easy to sell personalization
technology, and yet the way that we actually
implement it
is very, very challenging.
The data doesn't match what we
actually hope it to do.
An AI is supposed to fix these
problems,
but quite often it actually exacerbates
them. When you think about a marketer
with a really powerful AI tool that
lives outside of the content layer, suddenly
using that AI tool to create a bunch of
content, that's when we get that
poor quality content, that's when the content
gets worse.
So,
how do we actually fix this?
Well,
that's the next step of the, the equation.
Good personalization,
good AI native
personalization
looks very differently than
that past experience.
In the first place, it's gonna be based
off of structured content.
Content where
the
definition of what is a hero
is very, very clear, and that it can
be reused across a mobile app,
a website, a kiosk,
maybe even a watch.
Second,
we want automated guardrails
so that our marketers are able to create
safely. When they publish
content, they know that it's going to adhere
to the brand guidelines, it's gonna fit
within the front end.
This is what I think of as like the boring part of
like old fashioned content management systems,
but it's a critical part of what makes
content operations actually successful.
And if you just add AI on the side, it
doesn't actually work.
The 3rd thing we need to be able to make
sure that AI native personalization succeeds
is context-aware
content generation,
which means
The AI has an understanding of
the content model.
What is a hero in relation to
a landing page?
It has an understanding of the context of the user.
Did they bring with them a UTM parameter?
Did they bring with them a refer?
Have they clicked a link in the last 5 minutes,
in the last 5 seconds? Did they just
click a link 50 milliseconds
ago? And we also need
the context of the marketing
organization itself.
What are the brand guidelines?
What is the tone and voice that we want to
apply in this particular channel?
Very lastly, we need an API
first delivery layer, something that is
going to be able to deliver that content
regardless of where it's gonna be used.
We want all of these things to come
together in a content layer
that works in tandem with
the AI
so that we can personalize the content
based off of where it's going to appear,
for whom it's going to appear, and what
they're actually trying to achieve,
what we want them to achieve.
And so that brings us back to that idea of
the content collapse, marketers going kind of nuts
because too much is going on.
The truth is that we have
content be
the differentiator for how we can
actually build customer experiences.
I'm sure that some of you work in
tech companies
who are marketing your products to
prospects.
How do you compete against your competition? How
do you actually communicate that your
product is different and that your company
is going to do business differently?
Personalized experiences are the
opportunity to target that content
and build curated journeys
for the prospects that you are targeting.
To do that, we need to collect a lot of
information. We need two
main kinds of context. The
first, let's call them behavioral
signals,
those real-time signals that actually tell
you about what that user is doing in
that very moment when they come to your
website. And the second
is all of the other things
that they've done in the context
of your brand before.
Maybe they're part of an email campaign, maybe
they've purchased something in the past, maybe
you can actually identify that they work at
company X, Y, or Z.
So you got your behavioral signals and
then known customer characteristics,
those sorts of things that we can ascribe to somebody
based off of what we know.
The first is a real-time problem.
How do we collect that and make it actionable
right away?
How can we receive the signal from the front
end, use it to segment that user
into an experience, and give that experience
to them
without any sort of delay?
And in the second,
it's an integration problem. How do we
activate the data that lives
inside the CRM or the CDP
or the warehouse?
When we have both of those,
then we can start combining those to
create the contextual
information that's necessary to
provide a relevant, high quality,
compelling experience for
the user.
And when we do that, we should experience
improved conversion rates,
improved engagement, we should be able to drive
repeat behaviors and improve lifetime
value of our customers, and we should be able
to move them through the funnel with less friction.
But
all of this breaks down if you don't
trust the process,
able to scale it,
or have access to all of that
lovely context.
That's where AWS steps into the
contentful equation.
We partner, and I mentioned this earlier,
we're built on AWS
because it's the same infrastructure that you
all are trusting with your businesses
today. It's a critical part of
our value proposition to our clients
that we can be built on a solution
as robust and scalable as AWS
is.
But it's actually Amazon Bedrock
that gives us the special artificial
intelligence powers that we offer
within Contentfold.
Bedrock allows you to use
the generative AI models that
you've determined as an
organization with all of your governance and
workflows associated with them,
with all of your security applied
to them without a whole lot of fuss.
And Contentful brings Bedrock
directly into that content layer
to rewind. For a second, I said earlier
that if you just have AI in a sidebar,
you're just compounding the problem and giving
marketers a bunch of tooling that is a
little bit too big for their, their sort of scope.
But if you actually build AI using
Bedrock into the tools they use
to create, publish, and distribute content,
then you get something much different and
more powerful. Because
it's in that content layer that you
already have defined, what is your content model?
What is that hero? How does it play in
your mobile app versus your website? It's
already where you're storing your governance, your
approval workflows, and it's already
where you have all of that customer-based
data, the context that allows us to segment
the users.
So, let me take
a quick second to show you how it actually works.
I just want to add a disclaimer that this reference
architecture.
Is not for my audience and
maybe it'll be for you more than it's for me.
But when we think about, uh, the
way to actually combine bedrock and
contentful, we put contentful at the
center. We add a structure
around the content, we provide
governance and workflows. There's permissions
and roles for who gets to work on
the content and how.
And then we flow into that Amazon
bedrock, which is the intelligence engine. That's
the learning model, that's the way
that we're actually going to activate artificial intelligence.
It creates content, it localizes
content, it suggests new variants,
and it helps us identify users
based off of the confluence of actions
that they've taken recently.
And then wrapped around both, we have
the API first composable
architecture, the surface area
for the website or the app that's
going to consume the content
and display it for our customers. It's
essentially the front end.
Contentful exposes all of the
content and experiences through those APIs, which
means that we can distribute that content
to the channels that are being used.
This gives you three things.
It gives you speed
because content and AI all work
within the same platform.
They are decoupled,
so yes, you manage Bedrock separately
from Contentful, but they work together.
Gives you safety because governance
lives in the content layer, so the
same rules that your marketing team
used in the past
to publish content apply,
and it gives you scale because of course
AWS underpins everything.
The scale and infrastructure that it offers
gives us the sort of robustness and
assurances that we need to be able to provide
experiences.
So,
Contentful orchestrates the content,
Bedrock is the intelligence layer,
AWS scales, and your
experiences are able to adapt in real
time. So
to be able to make this really work, we need
to build a program around
personalization and testing.
The ability to optimize our
experiences and be able to
create something that is data-driven and
informs future decisions around
content is what we want to achieve.
But to get there, it's actually iterative
and small. We want to be able to
empower marketers to experiment.
And be able to collect data about
those experiments we want to be able to
measure the impact and align them with
business goals
because ultimately what we're trying to do is we're
creating a
program that will get credibility from
the rest of the organization to be able to
continue investing efforts into that
if you do. Big bang
release of something and it doesn't go the way that
you want, it's going to be another 2 years
before you try again. So if you can do it incrementally
and start small,
make an important change that has an impact on
business,
then you're going to have a really great
opportunity to create that life cycle and
that sort of flywheel effect.
And we also need governance to
be an important part of the equation.
I've said it a couple of times.
From Bedrock's perspective, that means
that you're using your own LLM.
It's your own cloud or your own
llama.
From Contentful's perspective, it's
the roles and permissions that somebody needs
to be able to work on content and publish
it to the front end.
It's the audit logs, it's the workflows
and approvals.
When you have AI live directly
within the content layer,
you can access all of that content, context
and structure to be able to
make the marketers empowered to publish
content easily and smoothly without
a major deploy.
I'm gonna skip this for a second
and talk about an example in the real world.
Our client Kraft Heinz
has been able to roll out dozens
of experiences using Contentful
and AWS,
and their experience at scale
has been able to drive incredible
business results.
Before they worked with us,
they had content scattered across many different systems.
They worked with.
CMSs, there was inconsistent governance,
and there was no way to create consistency
across brands or regions and
localizations.
Afterwards, they brought Contentful
in to unify their content portfolio.
They have workflows to be able to govern
different brand experiences in a unified
way,
and they're able to use real-time
personalization.
To be able to target
the experiences that actually drive
business results for each
of their brands and portfolio clients.
The results speak for themselves.
78% increase in conversion,
30% increase in engagement,
over 180 personalized
experiences launched across many
different brands
across the globe.
And so that brings me to the end.
I'm glad the last slide was the one that almost didn't work.
Um, I've talked about how to combine
contentful and bedrock and how
bringing the AI closer to the
content layer
gives the marketers the ability to get
out of that content collapse. It
helps them make better decisions
about the content that they're delivering to their
users. It helps them create
speed and trust
within their sort of workflow.
Uh, we have a booth over at 1457,
where you can see it in action.
I'm just the sales guy, but I've got an amazing
guy over at the booth who will show you how this
works and how it can work for your organization
today. Thank you very, very
much. If you have any questions, I'll hang out over
there. Uh, and I really appreciate
your time and attention today.